[Music]
damn angeline it's so
big
i bet people will talk about this 100
years from now
oh oh my god
it's working
since i was a girl i've known that fame
is my destiny huge gigantic fame
so i said i'm going to get the love of
the world
billboards are popping up around the
city featuring the striking image of a
blonde with a single name
angeline angeline angeline angeline
angeline
the billboard queen oh
yes
but it can be hard when you become
famous
a lot of people want to be a part of it
no matter what it takes
so they'll say and write just about
anything she was the devil in disguise
my dad paid for those money's her bottom
line not people
i'd love to be like barbie she won't cry
she doesn't hurt you are crazy i'm done
contrary to what people think
i'm actually very private people should
respect that
everybody want to know who is this woman
you'd look up the sky and there she was
this whole angeline story he starts with
me that did not happen he's completely
delusional
when angeline showed up ellie needed her
who is the real angeline don't you like
the not knowing
i remember that so
differently
i'm something that you have to
experience
i'm an innocent little
or dog star
i'm whatever you want me to be
but i do not want to be famous for
something that i do i want to be famous
for who i am
[Music]
that's the only story you need to know
[Applause]
[Music]
you